After having been...
We've traveled as a family for
the past few Thanksgivings.
And so this was sort of the first like...
Well, we did like the Friendsgiving
thing years ago, but--
Right.
This was kind of
a new group of people
and the people who invited
us we were very close to,
but then they kind of
invited a lot of people
that they know that they're close to.
So there was people that
I had seen like once
and there was people I'd never seen.
There were like 25 people
at this Friendsgiving.
Which is big in LA.
Yeah, 'cause you got all these people
who don't go back home
and nobody is with their
extended family and so--
You don't wanna find
yourself alone at a Sheetz.
And you got a lot of single people,
you got a lot of young
couples without children.
And so I think it was
basically just me and my kids
and then one of their family
and their kids were the only
like families with kids.
And then everybody else
was younger, more vibrant.
I saw a picture of the group,
sharp looking group, big group.
I'd say it was 24 people there.
It was 20 to 25.
25 people.
Yeah, yeah, and you dressed
up a little bit for it.
I did?
I thought that you did.
It looked like you were wearing a sweater.
I had a sweater on, yeah.
I have a Thanksgiving sweater on.
Yeah, yeah.
It's made out of turkey feathers.
If you'd been close enough
you could have seen that.
I had to zoom in.
I had on my cranberry pants.
But you couldn't see that
because of the angle.
The pants were made out of like the--
The skins of cranberries.
The skin hangs off at turkey's neck.
Yeah, right.
They're just bright red.
And wrinkly. Looks like
leather, unless you get close.
Like a turkey's nut sack.
Scrotum pants.
But the scrotum does hang
from the chin of a turkey.
Dot.com.
So I was very excited because,
you know me, I love to eat.
And I was very excited because
the friend of the person
who was kind of throwing this was like,
they're gonna take care of the food.
A few people did make things to bring
like my wife made a sweet
potato casserole, Southern style
with some pecans on top, brown sugar,
just traditional
Thanksgiving side, very good.
And here's what I'll say.
I call that a pre-dessert,
not a side note dessert, but anyway.
I enjoyed the meal quite a bit.
You had your staples and you turkey gravy,
your cranberry sauce, chutney, whatever.
And then like the sides
that people had brought.
But I did notice something.
First of all, there was
obviously a vegan option
for basically everything
and this is Los Angeles.
So you got like a vegan option for the...
But it wasn't like a tofu turkey.
They had like seitan,
which I call Satan.
I just go straight for that.
It's very big of you to invite Satan
to your Thanksgiving celebration.
Satan steak, we have cut him up
and served him on Thanksgiving.
Be thankful for his death.
But the thing that I kinda noticed is that
the only thing on my plate
that had the quantities
of butter and sugar and flour
that I feel like constitutes
Thanksgiving was what my wife brought.
And I gotta say, I know that
that's just a Southern boy
coming to Los Angeles.
I specifically remember
one of the first potlucks
we ever came to when we
came out here, this--
It was quite the eye-opening,
mouth-shutting experience.
Yeah, yeah, it was like,
all these people brought all these sides.
And this one girl was like, "I made this.
This is Paula Deen's recipe."
And I'm eating it, I'm like, "Really?"
And then as I'm eating it, she's like,
"And you know what?
I used half the butter and half the sugar
that Paula called for
and it's still good."
And I'm thinking, "Paula knows best, bro.
If you've seen the
silhouette of that woman,
she knows how much butter
and sugar you're supposed
to put it things."
Right, right.
And there's just a different mentality.
And you know what?
It's probably a better mentality.
It's probably a mentality
that leads to a longer, healthier life.
But when you--
Thanksgiving only comes once a year.
But when you've decided to
throw caution to the wind,
I could have--
Unfurl the sales.
I could have butter injected directly
into my veins on Thanksgiving.
I would do that if that was a thing.
We can make it a tradition.
And so 'cause dessert time
happened and I was like,
"Oh, there's a pumpkin pie."
And they had labeled everything
and it was pumpkin pie vegan.
Vegan.
And I was like .
And there was like
chocolate pie raw vegan.
What?
And then it was like
some kind of bites vegan.
Man
And--
Now you know how vegan
people normally feel, right?
And so what I thought
was, I was just like,
"Man, I just wanna go to Ralph's right now
and just get a pumpkin pie from Ralph's."
Just get a grocery store pumpkin pie,
put some whipped cream on top
and then unbutton my pants
and enjoy myself.
Right.
You know?
So that was an adjustment.
It was an adjustment
that I feel like I can
be ready for next year.
I think I'm gonna bring my
own butter and my own sugar.
I'm just gonna squeeze, squeeze, squeeze.
IV, bring an Ivy bag.
Like squeegee a butter,
and then looks like a sugar shaker.
And I'm just like, "Don't mind me."
Just to kind of get
things up to the standard.
Just bring stuff and label
it unapologetically unvegan.
Yeah, right.
That sounds like a good brand.
Oh, yeah.
And then the tagline is,
"Make it a tradition."
We sell it at Walmart and make millions.
Don't commercialize my holiday slogan.
I can't help but commercialize things.
I helped a lot of people, man.
But one--
I didn't make a dime off of it.
One traditional thing that
happened is the host said,
"We're gonna go around
and we're going to say
what we're thankful for
and we're gonna do..."
Because it's Los Angeles,
you kinda had to say,
"We're gonna do the cliche thing.
And we're gonna say what
we're thankful for."
And everybody was saying kind
of the traditional things,
family and friends--
What was your gut, knee-jerk reaction
to that announcement?
Well, I--
I can think of three.
What was my gut, knee-jerk
reaction to having--
To the announcement of the assignment
that this cliche thing was gonna happen?
Well, there's always a slight
increase in heart rate.
Yeah?
I think that every normal
person, even somebody who--
Don't speak for people.
I'm asking for you.
Don't normalize your response.
Just tell me what yours was.
I'm curious.
Well, a slight increase
in heart rate.
Okay.
And then--
That's normal.
Most people that would--
And then like, okay, I gotta say something
that sort of mixes humor
and heart in the right way.
This is a branding moment.
I don't exactly remember what
I said I was thankful for
'cause there was a second question
that I do remember everything
that I said which--
You don't remember what
you were thankful for?
No, it was something about
new friends and family
and then I made a joke.
It went over well, trust me.
But then the second thing that happened
while we were eating, which
I found very interesting
was there was a guy there
that was a life coach.
Again, of course.
Was he paid to be there?
No, if you get 25 people
together in Los Angeles,
one of them will be a life coach.
So--
That's code for something, right?
I dunno where--
If you don't have one
life coach per 25 people
in Los Angeles, the entire city implodes.
It's funny that the cashier
at Sheetz was a life coach.
So.
Did he have like a tag?
How did you know he was a life coach?
Well--
A hat?
If someone is a life coach
or a vegan or into CrossFit--
You know it, yeah right.
You know what I'm saying.
You find out pretty early
in the conversation.
Right, right.
So I--
That's true.
He stands up--
I got list of those things.
He stands up and he says,
"We're gonna all answer this question."
And again, I liked it
because it was intentional conversation
and it was 25 people at a
table and you're kinda talking
to the people around you,
but then he's kind of putting
everybody on the spot.
Even the kids, both of
my kids had to stand up
and answer this question.
But it was the traditional question of,
if you had a superpower, what would it be?
And what would be your first mission?
Oh, I actually haven't heard,
what will be your first mission?
First mission was new to me
'cause that's the kind of thing
that a life coach adds to it.
You understand?
Right, right.
'Cause what's your favorite superpower?
That's just normal folk.
What's your first mission?
Life coach.
Business card, here you go.
But the heart rate goes up
even more when that happens.
Yeah, I'm like now--
Curve ball.
Now, it's precious time to shine.
So I said, and it was...
One guy requested, he said,
"Instead of going around,
can we just do popcorn style?
Can we just, as you know,
what can use share?"
I was like, that's a good idea.
Why is that a good idea?
He wanted to get dibs
on visibility or something.
Because of the inevitability
of it coming to you and
you're just thinking
about what you're gonna say.
He had a reason, it was good.
I thought it was great at the moment.
But I had actually had
this exact discussion
with my wife the week before.
Now, we've talked about what
our favorite superpowers
would be before we argued about it
at some point on a debate around my sink.
If you believe in freedom,
you believe in flight.
Invisibility is to hide
yourself from freedom.
Like a shameful, naked mole rat.
Don't be deceived, flight is not heroic.
It is self-absorbed showboating.
Look at me, I'm air swimming.
I can't remember anything
that we do around here,
but I know we've talked about
superpowers and I personally--
Invisibility versus invincibility
was one of our first--
But we did invisibility
versus flight and then--
Yeah, we did.
I've always said
that teleportation is the
superpower that I would choose
because it technically can
replicate invisibility and flight
for all practical purposes.
I would...
Are you asking me now?
'Cause I would choose
being able to double myself
and be invisible so I
could creep on myself
and not even know it.
Well, interesting and disturbing.
But I did not say that
because that's just a canned answer.
I actually said what I
talked to my wife about.
But this is Thanksgiving,
you don't eat canned ham.
Jessie and I were with each
other, eating something,
and I was eating some bad food.
Is this a dream?
No, no, no.
You lost me.
This is the week before
that gave me the answer
to the superpower thing.
Okay.
And I said, "You know what?
If I could have a
superpower, it would just be
to turn everything that
is bad for me to eat
into things that are good for me."
The whole thing would just flip.
So it would be like, fried
chicken, processed meats,
and not only would it tastes good,
but it would make me feel the way
that good, healthy food would feel
and be synthesized by your body.
So did you tell them this
and did that just incriminate
you in what you were...
the thoughts you were consumed by?
So I was like, "I'm gonna go early
so I can enjoy everyone's answer."
Oh, I like that.
So people got up and
said a couple of things
that were kinda fun, kind of interesting.
And I was like the third and I said,
"Well, I've actually
been thinking about this
'cause Jessie and I were
talking about this last week
and I said that I would turn
everything that's bad for me
into things that were good for me.
And my first mission
would be to start eating.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.